-Today's Friday and that's
usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
of course send out
thank-you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running a bit behind.
Would you guys mind if I
write out my thank-you notes
right now, is that okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh, James,
could I get some thank-you-note
writing music, please?
♪♪
-Wow. Peppy, I don't know.
-Smirking, like the Mona Lisa.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it, yeah.
Is he smiling or not?
-Thank you, NFL Playoffs,
for not being called,
"are you better than a
50-year-old."
[ Applause ]
I don't know if you are or not.
-Maybe not. [ Laughs ]
-Thank you,
KFC's Beyond Fried Chicken,
for being a new fast food
product that doesn't contain
any actual chicken.
[ Light laughter ]
Or as McNuggets put it,
[Southern accent]
"Stay in your lane, girl."
[ Laughter ]
Stay in your lane, girl.
-McRib.
-Thank you, gloves, for being
mittens where the fingers
decided to pursue solo careers.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Thank you, targeted ads,
for showing me products
that I might like, while also
really hurting my feelings.
[ Laughter ]
Neck Spanx?
-Neck Spanx?
-Face Spanx?
What is face Spanx?
Never heard of them.
Kind of insulting but I could
use them.
-Like, well I'm definitely gonna
try it.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Thank you, cough drops,
for helping out
the people around you by
replacing your annoying cough
with an even more annoying
hard-candy sucking noise.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-[ Imitates sucking on a candy ]
Crinkle.
-There used to be to --
ah, there's used to be, like,
an old Sucrets commercial.
-Yeah.
-Where a guy really just went
for it and sucked on that candy.
-Yeah, he goes [Imitates sucking
on a candy]
-And you go, alright, alright,
alright, alright, okay, okay,
I'll buy the stuff, you gotta
stop making that noise.
-We used to get Luden's.
Like, remember Luden's?
-Yeah.
-Cherr-- oh.
-The chewy ones or the --?
-No, no, no they're hard.
Like cherry lifesavers but they
were cough medicine.
-Oh, yeah, of course.
Oh, yeah you'd throw them down
like they're cherry candy.
I love them.
-Yeah.
-Oh, I like this one.
I mean, I haven't
written it yet.
-You haven't written it yet.
-But in my head.
-You like
what you're about to write.
-In my head.
-Yeah.
I-I'm thinking I'm gonna write
something good.
-It's because
you're so thankful.
-I'm gonna write something good.
-No, it's good.
[ Laughter ]
-Grateful, so proud of you.
-Wait, don't let me forget it
now, hold on.
-Don't forget it, because this
is an important one.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you, welcome mats
that say something quirky,
for basically telling your
guests, "Yeah, we're a lot."
[ Laughter, Applause ]
-Just so you know.
-Just so you know, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, look "live, love, laugh.
-Like the weird wind chimes
didn't give it away.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, it's dog bone!
-Oh, there's three different
wind chimes.
So, wow that just sounds --
that's distracting.
-Mm, an Abbyson chair
on the porch.
-[ Laughs ]
-Do you like this one?
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Haven't thought of it yet.
Haven't thought of it yet, but
thank you, though or asking.
-Oh. Yeah.
-Thank you, hot toddies,
for being perfect
for when you can't decide
whether to cozy up on the couch
or get crunked.
[ Laughter ]
There you have it.
Those are our thank-you notes.